Star Trek tube yes that's how I'm
opening Star Trek to Star Trek to dr.
McCoy walks over to a Captain Kirk's
house I think it may be he's an admiral
by then and has a bottle of Romulan ale
this has bothered me since I saw the
movie I think I finally know why if it's
an ale that means it's made with an ale
strain of yeast al strains of yeast
don't flocculate they float at the top
of a ferment instead of sinking to the
bottom like lager strains do but that
also means that they produce carbon
dioxide because that's an outcome of
fermentation it also means there would
have to be bubbles the Romulan ale
didn't have any bubbles it was packaged
in like a 750 ml bottle you know it
wasn't in a six-pack also it was blue
now I would have thought it was a distal
eight not a nail right they take
fermentation you put it through the
still you get a distal a but colors
pigments don't make it through
distillation but the Romulan ale was
blue so what was in that stuff
that got me thinking about a lot of the
other booze in science fiction because
it's really problematic I'll give you
another exempt from Star Trek blood wine
Klingon blood wine right well a wine is
a product of fermentation the yeast eats
sugar and basically poops out ethanol
and carbon dioxide but there's not
enough sugar in blood for the yeast to
have anything to eat at least not in
human blood no maybe Klingon blood is
different right maybe Klingon blood uses
sugars or starches as a structural
element that moves the oxygen around
like we have hemoglobin I mean Vulcan
blood is based on copper and ours is
based on iron so there could be a
difference there but maybe ethanol is
not the psychoactive compound at all in
these drinks right I mean I'm making an
assumption that it's the same kind of
fermentation and distillation we do on
earth maybe there's something else
entirely you know the the systems in the
brains of the Romulans and the Klingons
could be totally different um you know
old Jencks spirit from the checkers
guide universe actually inhibits
telepathic abilities how does that work
and all we know about butterbeer from
Harry Potter is that it makes you feel
warm inside right on Star Trek they made
that stuff in the Replicators synthehol
which got you drunk but didn't get you
drunk I never really understood how that
what you can breathe the other universes
are even more confusing right we know
that they drink for recreation in star
wars because they have cantinas right
but you never some what they ordered
Luke I think says I'll have one of those
right which is a nice little elision and
I guess supposedly you could imagine
that the blue milk that Aunt Beru poured
was a like mohawk plus or something but
they never really say gets even worse
than that will star Galactica right
Galacta we know that Admiral Adama had a
stash of something that looked like
whiskey right it was he drank it in
shots and it was brown so that means it
was probably something that was clear
and then aged in a barrel and that's
where the brown color would have come
from but they also had a ambrosia on
caprica which I think was green and they
said smelled a little bit like sulfur
now sulfur is an off product it's an off
flavor in in distilling it means you
don't have enough copper in the process
because the copper pulls the sulfur out
so if you have sulfur in it that means
they hadn't made a mistake or the people
on caprica have a palate that's totally
different than ours and once they were
on Galactica they had a still right
chief Tyrol helped them build one so
experience for moonshine suggests that
that was probably you know whatever
sugar they could get ahold of and
whatever energy they could get ahold of
but it still takes heat so where do they
get the waste heat from maybe the
engines gave off heat but we don't know
how the Galactic engines works maybe
Battlestar engines are actually cold we
don't know
plus you would think if you were on a
starship you wouldn't want to be using
yeast to do the fermentation before you
distill it because the yeast gives off
carbon dioxide you would think carbon
dioxide will be an enemy on a starship
right because you wanna breathe oxygen
on the other hand if you were also
growing plants on the starship maybe
you'd want carbon dioxide because then
the plants wouldn't Hale the carbon
dioxide they would give off oxygen you
to have a closed system it's a little
simpler on planet side I think because
then you could probably terraform and
bring in your own plants that would it
be sugar or starches that you could
convert into sugars you probably have to
bring your own yeast too in the Star
Trek universe all of the living things
are sort of based on the same DNA so you
can imagine that maybe they were yeasts
on a bunch of different worlds but you
can imagine what the off flavors are
like if you don't have a an ale strain
or a lager strain of yeast that's been
bred for hundreds or thousands of years
domesticated the way we did it on earth
actually I think the stuff that really
interests me is the really exotic weird
stuff in this book the sparrow science
fiction book I love and the sparrow they
the bear like aliens eat these gelatin
things
to get them intoxicated somehow what's
in those I don't know I read a fantasy
novel wants a terrible one where the
wine was blue I hate blue wine blue wine
why not
the one that I really want to know about
is intron remember intron they lean over
into that spring thing and they drink
out of their disks and they just talk
about how good the power feels and makes
their diets glow science fiction get on
some details I want to know what's in
the source of Prague